I was gonna ask you about you know Chris
Farley who we all worked with and knew
you worked with him very closely in
second city and I know a bunch of people
know this but I don't know if everybody
knows that you created his motivational
speaker character Matt Foley I wanted to
ask you about that process of coming up
with that character and writing it out
for Chris Farley how did that come about
we were rehearsing and and improvising
scenes after the main stage show and we
did some improvisation where we were
doing like an anti-drug speech to
students and it was improvised we were
goofing around and Chris did a version
of Matt Foley he didn't have the glasses
or the suit but he was just hectoring
the kids with that empty you know by
golly you kids are gonna get it together
you know it was just that voice of a
coach who's just really doesn't know
what he's saying and his but it's trying
to put a lot of emphasis in it and and I
just went home with that voice in my
head it was very funny and these I sat
down with a legal pad and and wrote up
that sketch exactly the way it's done
although Robert Smigel added him
smashing the table at Saturday Night
Live because we didn't do that at Second
City well you City he marched out the
door and everybody ran for the exits so
that they wouldn't be there when he got
back but so then I brought it in the
next day and holy crap Chris I mean it
was just amazing how it it just came to
life and filled that theater every night
my daughter asked me once what was the
the most fun you ever had doing what you
do and and I told her and I still I
think I still believe it would be the
eight shows a week with Chris doing the
motivational speaker because you know
I've never seen anything hit so hard
every time and Chris wouldn't leave the
stage until he made all the performers
laugh that was he was driven to make you
laugh when he did the sketch every
single night so he'd be throwing in
different things he come right in your
face pushing his glasses up and it was
the greatest it was pure awesomeness